there was a very interesting shift that
happened right at the end of 2019 which
I believe is now going to dictate a lot
of the narrative around the 2020 primary
for the first quarter of 2020 certainly
into and through the first few primaries
and the shift is that both Democratic
Party insiders and even some in
corporate media seem to have had like a
light bulb go off where they realized
wait a second Bernie Sanders might
actually win the Democratic nomination
now this is not an analysis of whether
Bernie could be Trump we've done that
analysis that's a separate story this is
not an analysis of Bernie's policy this
is not an analysis of whether Bernie
Sanders is a communist he's not we've
done those analyses this is about
something else
we've talked about the Bernie blackout
that took place during much of 2019 in
terms of covering Bernie Sanders
campaign in a serious manner by
corporate media and we've also talked
about the attitude of some in the DNC
that Bernie simply can't win others on
the other hand believe that Bernie could
win and were scared so they were meeting
about how to try to stop Bernie famously
Pete Budaj edge was even included in
some of those early stop Bernie sort of
meetings that were taking place about
how can we make sure that we deny Bernie
Sanders the nomination but in the last
few weeks of 2019 things changed we'll
talk about the fundraising piece in a
little bit but a few other things went
on number one
part of it was Elizabeth Warren's
collapse in the polls and she had nearly
tied to Joe Biden for first place in the
Democratic primary a few months ago she
has been on the decline since then she's
dropped to third place she's lost almost
half of her support from her peak a few
months ago much more solidly behind
Bernie more than four points behind as
of this morning now another part of it
is not just Elizabeth Warren's decline
what we've seen if you look at polling
is that many candidates were up and down
and sometimes eventually out while
Bernie Sanders on the other hand has
basically been steady for months and
months
other than some very small shifts so
think back Biden had that huge spike
when he formally announced up to 40%
then he dropped he leveled out every
debate he seems to lose some support
because his performances have been by
and large terrible and then gained some
of it back very erratic okay Elizabeth
Warren climbed as I mentioned all the
way up to almost hi Joe Biden we really
within the margin of error to tie Joe
Biden and then just started sinking
losing almost half of her support Kamala
Harris she climbed all the way up to 15
after one debate in which she had one of
these kill shots against excuse me
punching my microphone against Joe Biden
but then she relic relatively quickly
fell she ended her campaign a couple of
weeks ago as we told you
Julian Castro just announced that he's
ending his campaign Budaj edge had an
upswing didn't really seem believable to
many people and he has settled back down
basically to where he was and this
entire time Bernie Sanders has been
holding steady even his heart attack
only a relatively small bump now there's
two ways to interpret that and I have no
interest in pulling the wool over your
eyes one way to interpret that is that
Bernie Sanders has a very solid base of
support
from which to build and now the question
is how does he build it and we'll talk
about that the other way to think about
this is that Bernie has basically maxed
out that Bernie has hit his ceiling and
barring some very unlikely circumstances
it's great for Bernie that he's held
roughly the same level of support for a
while but he's incapable of growing that
support those are two different opinions
about this and we'll talk about that now
just before the new year
you saw Democratic officials party
operatives pundits all starting to take
Bernie Sanders more seriously David
Brock is a big Democratic insider he was
a Hillary Clinton Ally in 2016 he ran a
pro Hillary PAC in 2016 I was on a panel
with him at Politico back in 2018 he
said quote it may have been inevitable
that eventually you would have two
candidates representing each side of the
ideological divide in the party a lot of
smart people I've talked to lately think
there's a very good chance
these two end up being Biden and Sanders
Sanders now there is no denying that
Bernie Sanders is solidly not in first
place the more I look into things the
more I believe the polls about Joe Biden
and that Joe Biden is solidly in first
place I know that there are a lot of
people in my audience who don't want to
acknowledge that what I have been
increasingly realizing and a call we got
last week or earlier this week actually
solidified that some of us are so
enmeshed in online politics where we say
where are these Biden supporters I'm not
coming across any of these Biden
supporters it feels like we rarely come
across them remember that call I got
explaining for a viewer explain that at
Christmas all of their relatives are
completely in for Biden they are not
voters that are part of the online world
that we exist in and I believe this
applies to millions of Americans so I do
believe Joe Biden is in first place I am
increasingly thinking about how could
the Bernie Warren support be
consolidated because I do believe that
if it could Joe Biden would no longer be
the frontrunner but we'll be talking
more about that as far as today's
conversation Bernie Sanders solidly in
second place being taken more and more
seriously by the establishment and by
corporate media the question now is what
can push Bernie Sanders over the top if
anything it seems as though Elizabeth
Warren going by the polls does not have
what it takes to go the distance her
support eroding by almost 50% over the
last few months the debates aren't going
to help Bernie I mean it just it we've
had a bunch now it's not moving Bernie
support I know that I still have people
in my audience who say David at the next
debate
if Bernie does X if Bernie does Y he
will take support from Biden Warren
whoever it's not going to happen in that
way unless someone seriously blunders
during an upcoming debate someone who
has significant support being Biden
Warren maybe Buddha judge but the
further in you get the less debates move
the needle unless someone really
blunders there is a bigger chance
that Bernie blunders and loses support
then there is that in the debates bernie
overtakes Joe Biden that's not about
Bernie okay I understand that this is
just the way the debate debates work the
further and you get the more candidates
are known the more their positions are
known the the smaller the possibility of
making large gains from the debates
becomes so it becomes a mathematical
question it's also a political question
how can support move to Bernie if that's
where you want to see the support move
what can you do I don't know the answer
Warren falling doesn't seem to help
she's lost almost half her support in
the last few months and Bernie's
basically even let me know your thoughts
what could change the balance towards
Bernie from where we are today a big
piece of evaluating how a candidate is
doing is fundraising in our current
system and I want to talk about that
next do you feel like you just don't
have enough time to become as
intellectually well-rounded as you would
like to be that there are just not
enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blankest comm slash Pakman
what blink is does is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work
I've just finished listening to upheaval
by Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a
tremendous author whose work I've
previously recommended excellent book
looking at some of modern history's
biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations
blinkie's has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety when I can
but there are simply just so many books
that I want to read and would not have
the time for if it weren't for bling
cast they have books on politics I can
comics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink as
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video